the quickest it believed at the time
when he's gonna get there he is if the
Lakers get another block as is Bradley I
believe Joe Todd Laker everything starts
with defense in the Lakers are
patrolling the pain and getting out in
the early offensive against LeBron Adele
did Anthony Davis showing them what they
came to see here I mean that pass
couldn't have been any better bounds by
kcpt LeBron look how perfectly that but
I LeBron was he come on oh that was nice
Lakers have ten points in the paint
already in this game Lakers have ten
points in the paint already in this game
[Applause]
timeout this team's turned it over by
Grumman and look at the Lakers go you
fit there up there
the Lakers go up 88-79 each other and
[Applause]
party continues DJ he's between Drummond
and drew and Dwight got to get buddy got
the short clock again with five LeBron
[Music]
[Applause]
you said he had made one tonight
triple that he had a second ago or a
minute ago that was the one because it
was a one-point game in that corner
three